[Music]
welcome everybody to the very first
official carful boys uh Zoom meeting
where we're going to go ahead and bring
in some of our top patreons uh thank you
guys for supporting if you want to end
up on here with us all you have to do is
be one of our Only Lovers and our that's
our highest patreon tier and if you are
in that tier you can be invited to be in
one of these chats so uh without further
Ado let's see what what happens when we
let these guys in go ahead
Anthony please no one please no one
weird Miss Christine is the first one in
the
room what up Christine
Abdul Abu Talib what's up Christine
oh we got two what's
up okay I'm gonna make it awkward is
that your guy or is that your
brother boyfriend boyfriend we go get
awkward we got a third person in right
oh
yeah how you how you guys doing what's
up dude where's everybody from
California OC OC oh hell yeah Califoria
baby I'm from Kuwait Kuwait let's go
what time is it over there it's 12:15
a.m. like
midnight yeah that's what 12:15 a.m. is
B
pajamas oh that's
comfy did you order a careful Boy shirt
I feel like a careful Boy shirt went to
Kuwait yeah yeah
yeah didn't you didn't you give us a
bunch of things uh written in
Arabic no that was uh I saw that but
that was some someone else okay okay my
bad no problem thank you thank you all
of you guys for being uh some of our to
pop supporters we're happy to do this
for you and we got wait Anthony say his
name correctly the Viet is
[Applause]
thaton what's up K what's up
Mar Ryan what's up where you from
Westminster oh Dallas Texas
oh yeah dude oh dude look at that shirt
look at that shirt yeah hell yeah
careful boys everybody dude so you guys
might have seen him in our comments on
IG a lot he's he's usually one of the
most active uh patreons that I catch on
there so I'll usually pin his comment at
the top uh welcome man good to finally
meet you hey nice to talk to you guys
yeah dude what's your IG
username uh it's I I spell it like c o u
n g because the way people are c u so
people can kind of pronounce
it but
I recognize you yeah yeah it it is kung
but like I I've been named kuang and
everything else because of Texans
everything else going up are those very
tiny Windows behind you or is those
pictures oh those are pictures okay got
it yeah just posters yeah you live in a
tunnel or something why is it so small
back there no this is just my game room
everything oh game room let's go yeah so
I I made my little office and everything
so h i i i I'm just pretty lucky enough
to own a home that you know has a a
theater room I made it into my office
and everything oh that's sick what Texas
better than Nevada uh I thought about it
cuz you see there's a outlet up there
that I was going to mount like a
projector that faces over here because
there's a theater thing over here yeah
but I never ended up doing that so um
trying to
brag
no it was just an idea it was just an
idea but like I got a I got a
refrigerated garage but I just store
drinks in there now I D they have these
short throw projectors have you seen
these things now they it can throw like
a whole 70 inch or up like from like a
foot away it's
insane yeah from a foot away like a
short throw projection my buddy has one
they're like 12 Grand it's [__]
ridiculous damn 12 Grand yeah dude damn
I haven't been in a Best Buy in a long
time to see new [__] like that dude that
shit's not at a Best Buy I'll tell you
that all right Room Tour room tour let's
go uh trity you're up next Trinity
You're Next Room Tour that's a dog clean
where you from oh you have a little dog
hey doggy what's your dog's name Bella
Bella licking me currently is your game
set up there dude okay monitors can you
get any more monitors are you a Trader
do you trade are you a stock
Krypto and I have one in front of me too
and yeah just couch tiny window tiny
window oh you're from you're from Dallas
too I see Tiny window I thought it was a
picture what game what game are you on
right now what's your what's your game
of choice at the moment seven days to
die I like zombies oh [__] oh you play
Pirate game before Pirate game no i'
[__] you up [__] you up I'd burn your
whole [__]
down dude that's tight all right Miss
Christine what's introduce us to your
man who's this yeah we got to meet him
yes this is T and TR and we've been
together for seven years holy sh
conratulations
but is he even allowed right now cuz
he's not a patreon supporter he's not
allowed
hey she's not watching he's not allowed
looking at something else I respect that
you got the deals I respect that one he
got with her so she could get close to
us Mark he waited seven years for this
moment he's anything so it makes it
great how' you guys meet uh at a piano
School in Garden Grove we wed we
pianists wait you took piano list as an
adult no no I I met him okay well I saw
him when I was 8 years old at a recital
he was 11 and then we got when I was 1
he was
20 you guys are pedophiles we got a
criminal on our
stream active criminal damn you've been
loving each other since you were kids
that's pretty crazy that's cute that's
true it's cute until you guys turned 15
now it's weird then it got weird started
real cute though that's
cool yeah that's why my is Miss
Christine cuz during Co I was teaching
students piano and Theory online oh
dope yeah let's go what's your favorite
key of the
plan oh oh any any key major
Keys major Keys man you ain't a real
pianist hey hey Miss Christine when your
guys around 15year old girls do you get
all jealous what oh no he's he's home
he's home playing games okay okay okay
you're like I remember when I was 15 you
you dog
you oh my God and for Anthony like I
went to Sunny Hills
oh
wow class of class of 15 years old what
201 2017 I
was holy
smokes you talk about it on podcast I
know what you're talking about for Sunny
Hills and the TC the plaza yeah what's
that one teacher's name who was dating
like the 18y old or whatever the like
15y old is he still there the guy to
your
left T Tran I
think was it we got somebody else coming
in the room oh let's see Sunny h b
what's up B Su B that's a badass
uh all right so when B comes in here you
guys this is one of our patrons that she
said she's going to downgrading soon so
we got to talk her out of it w she
actually said she's downgrading oh wait
no it's a dude it's a dude my bad that's
legendary what's up
[__] hey did you say you
downgrading to like only homies or only
got I'm downgrading I'm downgrading yo
no dude let us talk you out of it give
us if you're Dow you only have 34
seconds on this Zoom dud
Steve Steve work your magic convince him
dude I'm telling you there's no better
place where you get intelligent
conversations about real debates about
what's going on in the world that's true
that's true I agree with that I agree
with that talking about pedophilism and
stuff bit what what are your thoughts
I'll tell you what we didn't bring it up
I'll tell you that much yeah yeah yeah
what do you think about pedophiles
what's your take on them yeah do you
like them or not are you or no you more
of a thumbs up or a thumbs down on that
yeah or just like in the middle I was
like I guess I was label one yesterday
but
I were you really why were you labeled
one like legally labeled is it because
of your shirt I bet it's your shirt not
legally not legally it's the mustache
huh it's the it's the it's the roomies
the roomies oh is a big
misunderstanding yeah yeah yeah yeah you
call him a pedophile you got to throw it
out too if someone call pedophile you
gotta be like no tag bags oh yeah do you
wear that t-shirt when you host your
children's TV
[Laughter]
show me dude we got to convince him oh
man sunny but why you want to downgrade
B why you
want what's going on man um I don't know
I I just um I used to be in North
Carolina I just moved to California too
recently so what you do something like
that we're running away from
California what everybody saying that's
what everybody saying yeah what made you
want to go to California that's
crazy it is a little crazy change your
pace change of pace um yeah too you want
to start running from homeless men or
something you want a fast-paced life
there more children here yeah we
got oh d
if you're moving to California that
means you have way too much money and
you shouldn't be downgrading
then that's a good point that's a good
point we're all we all can't afford
California that's why we're we left if
you're down to pay $9 for a gallon of
gas I can only for right
now that's fair we get it now you moved
to California are you the type of guy
who tells your girl like hey if you
don't give more blow jobs I'm going to
dump
youy I hope you got what you paid
for oh no this perfect perfect do you
have any questions for the careful boys
any anybody yeah um questions um
questions the only question would be
when is the when is the next uh meet up
with all the careful boys yeah yeah yeah
yeah I was going to ask that oh like
like iners Meetup or in oh D we should
do let's do me cler now see so that' be
cool let's do one in North Carolina yeah
that would be a good
idea only for residents of rally that's
it
exactly I haven't been in ages I'm G
move back for the meet
up tell us when you're about to move
back and we will do it in South
California
yeah would be cool though
would you guys actually be down to do an
event like that where we actually meet
people [__] yeah yeah hell yeah where at
down we should do it at the airport CU
that's where I meet everybody
apparently we should do a Mee at the
airport you have to buy a ticket to fly
somewhere to meet yeah we're meeting
through security cuz they we can use a
TSA as the security pretty smart pretty
safe actually pretty safe I'll meet you
guys at the
Southwest uh departure on gate 233 at
the Burbank airport is that your actual
flight
no I don't even think Burbank has 20 233
Lanes I don't think they have security
either dude that's why I
get all right let's go let's move over
to Kuwait in case you guys don't know
hey B you got a guy right next to you
this guy's Abdul Raman this guy's from
Kuwait what is life like in Kuwait
and and thank you for staying up so late
to to be a part real you're a g dude
than I'm sitting up because I'm waiting
for my wife to come back from a wedding
actually so oh she has nothing to do
with us you [__]
us
y dang she got invited to a wedding and
you
didn't weddings here are are are
different men's and women's wedding are
separate they're they're not they're not
the same wow it's like a bachor bachelor
what if you get too horny is there a
family ceremony where everyone gets
together or it
just is it is it just guys celebrate and
then just girls or do the families come
together too or like well it's it's a
like the engagement is is a separate
thing and then there's um where I guess
where they liked up the the marriage
contract the separate thing and then
there there there's a wedding ceremony
the the men the men and women are
different but then the groom and his
close family members and the family
members of the Bride they go over to the
woman side that's why they steal we
don't they Ste they do steal
it I mean they they they see them all
but it's pretty stressful you walk into
a room with more than 500 women that's
very stressful
dude wow not for askm 5000 I'll tell you
that right now let's go oh dude hey is
that like when all the Bridesmaids are
trying to protect and then the the
family has to come and then they'll be
like no no like and then they try to
negotiate and then the and then that's
that that's in Turkey oh okay okay okay
yeah that's a Turkish wedding if there
there are no brma or or best men here in
Kuwait it's I see it's just the the
groomman his family or the B family
that's all uh Abdul ran bro what do what
do you think very what do you think's
the wackest thing about
America great question well I mean I I I
was in Ohio I I got my bachel in Ohio so
I was in the US US for seven years oh
damn okay you know wor in America I know
I know that's that's what they chose for
me so I went there how did you meet a
jug yeah
do who did you meet a jug jug did you
meet two jug did you meet two jug
no jug so what did you what did you not
like about it about being here actually
um it's pretty hard to say it's not like
I didn't like it I wouldn't live in the
US per say honestly I would I would
visit a lot it's a lot of fun but I
prefer to stay in A Place With No taxes
so respect no taxes that's a humble bag
respect
there's like yeah no no State no federal
taxes no nothing no no no ta they've
been trying to enforce taxes for what
four years now so how does the
government make any money if there's no
tax oil baby big
sales Dam that's dope man out it runs
out which I don't care about it because
that's all my kids kids kids so I don't
really care about that dude do you do
you fill up your whole [__] like you
could fill up a van for like 25 cents
over there
huh um well okay let's say I I had a
Tahoe V8 and I fill it up for 30 bucks
30 30 bucks holy [__] dude so I have a
Silverado which is pretty much the same
thing um it's 130 every time oh Dam damn
and that's big I didn't I California
like when I was there I did not enjoy
gas SE when I was there wow uh what's
the number one misconception of like QA
like what people have it wrong and
they're like no like this I learned
everything about from George
Clooney three kings bro oh that that
movie The Three Kings movie is kind of
true about the gold thing but I'm I
didn't go too deep to that the biggest
misconception is that it's not a safe
place to live
in I heard that I heard that the biggest
misconception about about three kings is
that there's actually in Kuwait if you
live there there's way more elephant
writing camel actually way more no
camels camel in India India India
Thailand Thailand and India yeah it's
not eleph camel Steve three in three
kings they only did that like 14 times
and I I didn't really do it that
much isn't that nice to get actual
confirmation for someone in Kuwait Steve
actually is dude feels better right he's
like it's cable I'm like that's
sick I'm right cheap here but that's for
the kids all right if anybody has any
questions for Nick we're gonna take this
time to uh let the fans address Nick he
can't deflect this time he he not to
deflect yeah never
deflect kid what did you say I'm sorry I
you cut off for a second defle already
are you hiding in your
car what's up this I live out of my car
yeah I am slowly getting a little bit
lower yeah everyone's in their office
and I'm the only one in the car so
that's it's pretty
nice wait Miss Christine what did you
ask Nick oh how are your kids Nick oh
god oh dude they're let me tell you I
can talk about that all day bathroom
break time bathroom
break
just out the zo great we just went to
Yos we just took them to Yos that would
pretty cool you know yeah and they they
only ate their [__] twice that that's a
big
win I'm sorry you I'm my internet is so
bad she said that would you she said
would you rather [__] your mom or your
dad um I've answer this already and it's
my dad it's my
dad oh now Nick's asking all of the
patrons is that what you said yeah back
to you
guys all right wait wait wait dude start
thinking start thinking hard coming back
coming on the show let's start let's
start with Kung because I know I know
Kung probably already has
answer oh yeah I do it's got to be my
dad it's got to be cuz that that bastard
that bastard ditched me tried to ditch
me when I was a baby so oh you're GNA
pull you're gonna pull a j on him is
payback you riding his dick cowgirl
style no I got to tear him up a doggy
style
we got we got slide jumping on the the
zoom as well and slide right into a hot
question just in time just in time all
right slide would you rather [__] your
mom or
dad welcome by the way welcome by the
way sorry I pulled a hamstring so I was
trying to stretch it out you got a
cramp yeah I got a I got a hamstring
cramp out of nowhere I need to stand up
yeah those are what will it be Sly what
will it be yeah
what would you have on the
menu out there stretching oh we are you
can't hear s yeah we can't hear you both
he's he's
muted am I muted now there you
go mom or D there you
go all right it would be my mom by the
way that the freaking invitation went to
the spam box I've been waiting in the
car for 30 minutes
oh we're about to wrap it up here we're
don't worry you came at the perfect
time so why mom why
Mom [__] uh my dad my dad my dad's been
[__] over by life a lot of times dude
I think he needs a
break that's a good [__] answer a
chable answer the best
answer hey where you from where where
you from Sly um right now calling from
uh Seattle I'm explicitly basically um
ever at Washington I'm right off of work
basically I got out so they can do the
call then I'm going to get back in at
two oh I wish you were in your office
and everyone could hear what was
happening I I would get fired like like
that hey what's the hey what's your
watch brother what's that
watch um this this is just a c citizen
oh cool tight okay cool cool glasses by
the way thank you bro thank you don't
compliment thank
you I see Steve killing it on Coogi yes
sir just a little bit called it it just
a little bit just a little bit my DCA
was 72 cents not that good not that good
it's kind of crazy there's only 12
people here I'm surprised man crazy oh
we yeah there's only um we only invited
six of you guys we lost a lot of
followers yeah they're all downgrading
oh no D um like I guess I missed the
first half an hour um I don't know if if
they're supposed to take turns or
something I've been watching guys for
like 15 years now 15 years thank you
dude thank you bro wow awesome 15 years
like I wasn't even my country when it
started welcome dude you guys you guys
pull me through really hard times
honestly I owe a lot to you
guys you yeah where did you originally
move originally
so hard time
time you went through
man but I I love Bart's Bart's setup
right there like you doing or something
bodybuilding poses right now no I pulled
I pulled a hamstring so I had to it just
randomly cramped so I'm trying to like
stretch it out but then this is another
humble brag this is he just showing off
his ass yeah yeah say is you trying to
are you trying to Rouse us with your ass
yeah show your ass dude change your name
to Master
6,000 um but uh answer your question so
Palestine I grew up in Palestine like
West Bank
yeah oh wow did you pay 17 cents for
gas uh no actually we're [__] over
there the one gallon is like almost nine
bucks what oh my god wow you got
California
prices yeah yeah that's gav your guys
president no you got you got to you got
to go to Qatar or Saudi Arabia whatever
those those countries they have it yet
like it's cheaper than water guess over
there wow yeah crazy over there can top
off your car for like 10 bucks wow when
did you come to the states uh in
2012 oh nice and and then you move to
Washington I was um no I was I was in
Chicago for two and a half years in
Atlanta for eight and then I'm here
right now in Seattle just working for
Boeing right now oh [__] oh man that's
so scary that people who watch us design
airplanes man that's
Ser oh my god well done well done
manate how did you come across our
material it was so Random cuz I think it
was like um like Asian grandma or Asian
mod or something like it was like back
in high school like I watched some
random [__] on YouTube like back in the
day where equals 3 was a thing whatnot
and some video somehow your guys's video
cut justed and the first thing I saw was
Bart it was like one of the skits like
Bart was in it it was like Asian po or
something like that barely remember but
yeah but since then I've been following
you guys and as soon as just kidding
news came online I'm like I started
watching and it's been since then I've
been like every day oh thank you damn
thank you bro I thought I thought you
you were making a motion with hand like
since then it's been up and down
[Laughter]
exactly exactly wow this is this is
crazy by the way going to see Jason
chenny in in a month he GNA be
here I'll be sure I'll be sure ripping
the the just the careful boy t-shirt
merch I
got picture and uh and tag tag Us in the
story so we can repost and stuff I will
I will don't worry record this whole set
and upload it to YouTube
we'll do
that just keep heckling him the whole
time what you guys got cooking up at
Boeing right
now what's
the I guess I mean we got a few I'm
right here I'm like at the distri at the
factory oh [__] fact right here so we
got um we got a couple das9 I worked on
a-9 so it's like the new plane if you
flown on across the Atlantic or Pacific
you would be boarding like a plane
that's a that's a twin aisle so it has
seats on both sides and seats in the
middle wow um so the new plane is the
one replacing the 747 I don't know if I
can zoom in with this thing but it's
essentially it's over there that's the
factor over there I don't know if you
guys can see but dude in green those
planes over there those are what's been
cooking and then other planes you've
probably seen well so you got like a
respectable job cuz we got like other
like pedophiles on this Zoom call yeah
real weird you never know there's an Air
China One there's a Chinese Airline
plane right there getting ready to fix
up that's crazy that's crazy that's sick
dude are they going to be better than
the
747s they are so no they'll be hold on
let me flip the camera so they will be
they well size-wise they're kind of the
same but a 747 can fit more people but
they don't make them anymore the last
one rolled out like four months
ago can you guys make it so I can use my
[__] cell phone when we're flying
yeah what's going on dude what's up with
this [__] yeah what's the real story why
fly your phone
off huh what's the real story with why
you got to turn your phone on airplane
mode you're flying is it because you
guys completely suck at designing stuff
yes yes exactly that's what it is
exactly um Whatchamacallit no it it
basically certain radio frequencies like
the cell that works on interferes with
radio communications between the Tower
and the planes oh Sally and they don't
that yeah so if that affects the
communication you can run into accidents
where PL planes are flying you know
across like basically crashing into each
other whether it's at the airport you
know grounds or in the air cuz you have
hundreds of planes flying all the time
wow why come that doesn't affect the
small planes with from on like jet weed
X they don't give it two shits those
things work I mean those things work on
lawnmower engine it's not really that
complex you can you can avoid things
with it yeah got it um but yeah that's
pretty cool man I'm honestly this is
kind of crazy first time I ever I mean
I've never met any of you guys and even
with the
fans what 15 years I've only met two
fans of JK that run into
them you're doing a meet up in North
Carolina
soon northp
maybe there's not enough people at
Boeing that watch JK oh this is all over
I ran into like it was a flight
attendant that saw my hoodie my just
kidding just kidding news hoodie and
she's like oh watch this kidding news
it's like the flight attendant but she
was probably Whispering huh cuz she
didn't want people to notice that
she we have a lot of PSA and flight
attendant fans tons yeah tons that's
that's kind of working class huh yep yep
C representing every man let's let's
talk to Trinity for a bit she we haven't
really spoke to Trinity Trinity what's
your story where you at what's TR I love
the art on your
wall it's a window
dude
window I knew it
um where am I I'm like an hour or two
from La in a small sucky town which town
Barto zizzi
z Oh Filmore oh
Filmore where's town why is just buried
Filmore you just buried it yeah it's
it's I call it the pit stop town because
it's just gas stations and W stations
fast
food how did you how did your family end
up there your Christmases must
suck um so I've been living on bases but
recently oh me and my husband decided to
get a house for ourselves to make money
for the future so this was the best deal
oh hell yeah and it's gated I bet you
it's still a million dollar house even
though it's because it's in California
when you sell it on the flyer you're
gonna say it's in sucky ass
Filmore on the description it's the best
part of Filmore though oh oh that's good
that's good yeah all right cool you just
have to write it correctly it's little
town see you got write plaint little
town you know in the best part of town
and gated community you said g it
beautiful
new and then sell that thing for over a
million dollars because it's in
California and bring your butt over to
Vegas but how do you get there you got
to buy a plane you sell the house you
buy a plane and you fly the plane to
Vegas and then you sell at Vegas but
make sure you do it during a convention
or something popular like the F1 races
right now cuz then you'll have all the
rich people who are like I'll buy a
plane you know and now that we got slide
here we have a plane plug
yeah did you guys hear that they ran out
of private jet parking space and that's
what they're complaining about they have
RAC my god wow what a problem they they
also built like many acres of more um
parking spaces and they still fill them
all up so the Super Bowl's going to be
[__] dude cuz we're getting Super Bowl
here too and you guys got the athletic
A's moving over there too y just got
approved yep I think they're demolishing
the Tropicana to build a stadium
there wow they should Circus Circus hey
trity Trinity if there's if there's
something that we can do for the channel
to make it better in your opinion what
would that
be delete
it no it's already I think the I think
the best thing is when you guys bring
guests that fit your style and are not
afraid to be themselves too who's one
your favorite guest how how do you feel
about the guests on this Zoom right
now
oh back to Ryan's question that's that's
probably who do you like that we've had
on that we should have
back um I like to look at s m
um me either me either
uh I like chenny and the new people is
it the band that you guys have
on the band their band are you talking
about
UTI oh yeah U yeah they're another
podcast group yeah they're really
great they're cool yeah they're a
band just started it yeah chenny is a
classic everybody loves
chenny yeah yeah you guys been follow
for a long time so it's like I miss Gio
though we're not going to have her back
on a never is Gio there right now Bart
yeah is Gio at home let me see yay
was Nick was the replacement I hope he I
hope he can do it I don't think I'm tall
enough to be he's living up to it though
the ear makes up for everything
dude the ear makes up for height
yeah
yeah for
dude going to get you his hamstring dude
he W the door he [__] crawled to the
door he wob over yeah it's the best he
doesn't have those stairs and yeah
chenny uh I love having chenny on I hope
he does a comedy show near Filmore that
you can check out yeah la that I'll have
to drive to yeah all right or you going
to the LA show no no no know okay if you
do I'm
going I think the the closer one might
be Oxnard I know he does shows there oh
really I didn't know that that's closer
right um everything's far from this town
okay damn dude the hits just keep on
coming I mean I'm doing it for the money
well she she must not be here just shut
the doors no he's got to check all his
rooms he's got like 25 rooms
yeah come J's pretending to work like
she's busy oh but yeah maybe when she
maybe when she's done she could come
here she's pretending to when you go by
she's like typing aggressively like
she's been really working hard with two
fingers how about you Miss Christine and
is your husband also a watcher or is he
just kind of like here to monitor you
I'm a
watch I'm a big fan too I'm really oh
heck yeah oh thank you man what do you
think what would you guys want more of
on the
channel I like just kiding news to be
honest I really like news you actually
like the news part of just kidding news
I like yeah I like I like to watch
itake background so oh because I like to
listen and she does it too she likes to
drive and then listen to your guys
podcast oh cool hell yeah we more audio
based but I want your guys Partners to
be on too I love when you guys talk
about your
partners okay okay you like the
relationship stuff you like the [__]
on when the [__] are on
too makes
sense that's really good feedback
actually yeah that is good feedback yeah
I love relationship topics you guys have
so what about the relationship
topics huh should we talk more like what
would you what would what would be some
questions like that you would like us to
answer next OTR or whatever about
relationship stuff oh I don't think
about it think about it think about it
yeah think about it I'll write it down
wait how about this how about this you
can oh go ahead B go ahead I was going
to say do you like it when we say the
girl's always wrong or when the guy's
always
right which one yeah which one's better
girls always wrong or guys always
right for
you
okay that's the next topic you've been
in a relationship for seven [__]
years how'd you do it how about that oh
oh stubbornness cuz my parents triy to
break us up
really why they don't like them that he
plays piano no we're I was under at the
time he plays in minor Keys as oh
[__] that was really good Jesus Christ
that was good I just got so they they
were judging me because I left the
Marines early yeah for admin at admin
separation uh yeah so I was just like
Bart I was a reservist I was reservist
in 29 Palms and I was still in MOS
school and I left early I left during
MOS school so you could do that yeah
that's a
choice uh it was so special situations
happened uh yeah but yeah that can
happen feel free to divulge exactly the
details of the special situation
uncomfortable I don't know I don't know
there's [__] loopholes like that
that's maybe they just heard about your
love story and they had to kick you
out bad PR for the core
[Laughter]
man I think we hit it on the
dot all right what about uh what about
you be tell us what we could do to uh
make the channel better and keep you as
a upper tier Patriot he's dipping dude
what kind of value do we got to giveing
guys
uh maybe maybe more
videos more videos so you're an ideas
guy you're an ideas guy I get
it just make me uh just make uh just let
me join the game you know let me join
the game so you think like what three
uploads a day four uploads a day what do
you think it is is enough what upload
the kids on
them great
idea only person I met is Anthony too
but he making the most
[Laughter]
Jokes wait is that what you just said
yeah you
when uh theual pedophiles ball no no no
we're not supposed to talk about that in
public
ball I like how lazy rules and hilarious
that was at the same
time
ball I haven't been in six months all
right no where' you guys meet heading
the clouds the ohing the cloud cool this
year not not not this year but the last
year last year oh SN yeah yeah heck yeah
hey be honest though how did how did he
treat you how what was your impression
yeah was he cool was he a dick he mean
he's mean to me
dude he's prob big timing you the whole
time too yeah he's like I'm with Jackson
way no big dude he was cool he was cool
yeah he's pretty cool but I didn't know
um that was his uh future wife at that
time but oo
mhm
mhm clear that's all I got to say all
right hey that's good all right congrats
on getting the age of consent lowered
all right Abdul Raman what do you think
what's your opinion on JK news right now
how what would you like to see more of
man wow um say I mean
uh just like everyone I watch it really
casually you guys are a lot of fun to
it's really close to how our jokes are
how we are with each other oh cool it's
fun when you guys stereotype other n
other races and that's very
funny whether whether you guys have
background or not that's always funny
when you guys talk about Arabs and stuff
that I mean it's a lot of inaccuracies
but that's still funny and I know
everything I really wish no one correct
you we're very intelligent we're very
smart
hey that's that's a really encouraging
thing to say man I really like that you
said that and make sure you take notes
Ryan he wants us to talk more about
Arabs
yeah you got the from two of them
did yeah I'm I'm not gonna expose any
more stuff about Arabs so you guys just
just
go go go ahead what you think and if
anyone's pissed they can just piss out
themselves all right hey do you have any
cool statues in the room with you can I
see a cool
statue statue yeah you got to have a
cool statue Kuwait
dude oh no
no that's another guess misconception
great yeah all right Kong what do you
say Kong what's your opinion you've been
watching a long time you've been a
supporter a long time oh I think you
guys are doing fantastic but um you guys
are going up um getting all those um new
ticktockers and stuff I barely know them
you know and I get to learn about them
and everything else and you guys have
good chemistry like everybody that
you've got gotten in has great chemistry
with y'all you know and like Jason
Chappelle Chappelle's like really
Chappelle you know so like a lot of the
comedians Jose Jose and stuff like that
you guys just have really great
chemistry and I
love Jose
missus
I don't know his name is J J I heard
Mexican name I was like yeah probably I
know what you're talking
about who's yeah Jesus is a hit for sure
every time yeah you know and that's what
I I I always vibe off you guys in
general so like I can see that your
y'all's chemistry work and that's what I
love about y'all you know so and you
know ever since like the pandemic and
everything else and uh I just
um watch y'all more often than
everything else because this y y energy
just brings y'all together closer and
everything else and just makes me love
you guys a lot
more you too man even Anthony you meant
to say but except for Anthony
right yeah you know everybody except
Anthony yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm just
gonna go ahead and mute Steve so we can
have
[Laughter]
conversation
he
muted he really did it he's got Zoom
premium and I just unmuted myself look
at
that dude thank you guys for all of your
input and stuff like uh I hope we can do
this again with all of you um we'll
probably send out another email to the
top patreons whenever we do these but
thank you guys for your valuable
opinions yeah can I have of better yes
yes slly what's up man hey because I
never got to answer like what would you
approve I think whatever you guys are
doing is perfect as is the only thing
that I think that you guys would be cool
if you could do it and I know it's a
stretch but just do like live shows like
a live show at least once a year live
show like honestly a live
recording I would pay honestly I would
if you told me it was happening tomorrow
looking it right now and I'm com wow
that's awesome you say that CU Jus Jesus
had a had a recommendation once that we
do a JK comedy night where we have a
bunch of the standup people that have
been on the show do stand up and then in
between we host yeah yeah specific all
jokes about erab would you
guys hey you guys guys you know what's
funny the biggest thing that I bonded
over you guys like in over the years
whatnot it's like you are we're more
alike than you think and that's why I
actually agree with a lot of things you
guys said yeah and I'm okay with all the
racism you also do you also agree that
Anthony is a 911 Den or no oh he is he
is I mean I mean honestly can you just
tell him how delicate those [__]
planes are right now to his face sry B
we can't hear you anymore you're
muted show me the
no I love all of you
guys got it dude got him that shirt is
never coming out by the way so make
sure I got low I I did tell the guys
that are top patrons could purchase that
shirt because
uh yeah but only for display purposes
because I realiz most of you don't have
art on your wall
[Laughter]
so topat can get that shirt that's sick
hey can we can we if Anthony if we give
the money to the victims would you allow
us to sell the shirt the [__] up Steve
exactly exactly he doesn't want it to go
to the victims
exactly care told you told you it's cuz
he doesn't think they exist
exactly you remember how we were about
to end on a good note if we could just
bring that back and then we ended on a
great note
yeah so Trinity Kong Miss Christine
Abdul ran slide B thank you for joining
us if you can please DM the JK Instagram
uh so I and give you guys a follow back
thank you for being some of our top
patreons for so long um be whatever we
could do to convince you to stay let us
know for everybody else much appreciated
yeah
we're
guys let's do this again sometime and
and if we do I'll definitely uh I'll
keep all of your contacts on me and make
sure to notify you when we do all all
right but you joining us thanks for
giving us your time
pleas thank you
everyone
right let us know when you guys get your
tattoos don't get the
tattoos get the tattoos get the tattoos
we appreciate the earlier show but next
year next year earlier show fair oh yeah
earlier next time for Abdul yeah we'll
all stay up [__] late and you yeah
we'll stay up I'm down hey it might be
morning here Fair true true true all
right good night bro all right
later
later I don't believe he had no statues
I don't he didn't turn the camera around
I'm stoping hey I have plans here if you
want to see them let's see them dude
let's see them let's see them let's see
them
stop okay
okay see yeah that looks
yeah that that's Arabic actually that's
sick is that a Magic Carpet that say
live live love over here we over here we
put those on the
ground what over here we put those
on America yeah we put those on the
floor I I I I I can't because that
that's just something from the Quran so
I can't we really can't put that on the
floor
yes
you're great dudey you're the man yeah
he's really good thanks for being such a
good sport bro you're Anthony I hope
this is not recording but thank you for
being a 9911 denier since they put on on
the so I appreciate that
man God damn it
godam
apprciate come on come on don't don't
leave it hey dude vote for Bush next
time you come over to Ohio all right you
all right brother pleasure dude take it
easy
dud later boys see
me